[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 24 septembre
bienvenue dans le journal préparé par la
rédaction de tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité locale et 17300 le
nombre d'entreprises nez dans les
yvelines en 2018 pour donner toutes les
clés de réussite le forum je crée ma
boîte se dérouler aujourd'hui au ski
cuba guyancourt dans cette édition focus
aussi sur le salon et défi entreprendre
au programme ce vendredi à versailles
il est désormais beaucoup plus simple de
relier à pied ou à vélo mantes la jolie
à limay une passerelle entre les deux
communes vient d'être inauguré les
travaux de cet ouvrage qui surplombe la
scène avait démarré en février 2018
et puis cette inauguration est également
toute récente une spirale aromatiques a
vu le jour à bois d'arcy à l'initiative
du mouvement des incroyables comestibles
c'est la troisième initiative de ce
genre en france
j'accueille tout de suite mais deux
invités mais trois invités même autour
de cette table in dauger bonsoir bonsoir
est la présidente du club coc
entreprendre 78,12 organisé ce vendredi
le salon défi entreprendre c'est à
versailles entreprendre justement mais
deux invités mais deux autres invités se
sont lancés à dans cette aventure polka
c est également pire de châteaubourg
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes les co
créateur de la start-up caps votre
projet une capsule volante comme
solution de transport aérien du futur
reste avec nous on parle de ses sujets
dans un instant
[Musique]
mais d'abord c'était une première à
saint quentin en yvelines la journée je
crée ma boîte un forum sur la création
et la reprise d'entreprise organisé
aujourd'hui toute la journée à plusieurs
partenaires de saint quentin en yvelines
et du ski cube on est conseiller et
apporter des réponses à des
entrepreneurs le reportage de nicolas
landry et de rodolphe blondel
accompagnement financement expertise
réseau et immobilier d'entreprise les
acteurs de la création d'entreprise au
forum je crée ma boîte
un événement organisé par saint quentin
en yvelines et la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines objectif
conseiller et orienter les entrepreneurs
dans leurs démarches de création
la plupart du temps les porteurs de
projets viennent en disant j'ai une idée
je veux savoir la meilleure forme
juridique kim qui me convient et les
aides que je peux avoir
donc mon rôle dans un premier temps
c'est à dire c'est bien de vous poser
ces questions-là
mais ce n'est pas que ça avant il faut
poser votre projet par écrit pour savoir
si votre projet est viable
parmi les visiteurs cédric leroy son
projet créer une société de conseil dans
le domaine du sport avec pour cible le
marché indien j'étais un petit peu
perdues pour être tout à fait franc avec
vous il ya énormément de statut de
société qui existe j'ai pris des
renseignements un petit peu sur internet
mais je me suis vite rendu compte qu'il
y avait une limite à tout ça et que
c'était important de pouvoir échanger
avec des personnes
physique et a pris justement qui avait
un service international au niveau de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie ce
que je ne savais pas du tout donc j'ai
fait une prise de rendez vous et ils
m'accompagnent auront ensuite sur
justement le choix de mon statut
d'entreprise de son côté sybille capelle
veut développer une plateforme de
recrutement
une démarche après plusieurs années
passées en entreprise demandeurs
d'emploi elles se lancent dans
l'entrepreunariat un réseau qui est très
très bien ficelé et qui aide grandement
les créateurs d'entreprise dd l'embryon
d'idées donc c'est plutôt sympa statut
juridique protection sociale étude de
marché des thèmes abordés dans ses
ateliers à l'intérieur du ski cube c'est
des ateliers de 45 minutes généralement
il ya une demi-heure en fait
d'intervention du formateur de l'expert
de la thématique et derrière il ya
toujours 15 minutes d'échangés avec les
participants au premier trimestre 2010 9
plus de 5200 entreprises ont été créées
dans les yvelines
plusieurs événements dédiés à
l'entrepreneuriat sur le territoire des
yvelines vendredi prochain c'est le
salon défi entreprendre qui est soutien
au domaine de madame elisabeth à
versailles line dauger vous êtes la
présidente de l'association co
entreprendre 78 qui organise ce forum
entreprendre aujourd'hui est ce que
c'est un véritable défi je vous fait
réagir déjà sur le titre de ce salon
mais fier entreprendre tout à fait alors
on illustre justement ce défi
d'entreprendre de sous trois aspects le
premier aspect c'est de savoir
construire et structurer son entreprise
sur des bases solides et comme l'une de
nos valeurs a ajouté nous c'est
l'innovation sur les méthodes de
l'entrepreneuriat vie nous utilisons
donc nous allons illustrer cette méthode
du lean start-up que vous devez
certainement vouées start-up heures déjà
peut être utilisé pour justement savoir
construire son business model ce qui est
essentiel n'est ce pas de manière
efficiente et rapide donc c'est une des
premières
manière de répondre à ce défi
entreprendre la deuxième manière c'est
de savoir s'entourer son tour être
durablement de savoir valoriser les
compétences de savoir évidemment
recruter les bonnes compétences et les
conserver faites les modèles aujourd'hui
ne pas être le seul dans cette démarche
c'est primordial alors c'est la raison
d'ailleurs d'existence de notre réseau
mais évidemment nous ne sommes pas le
seul réseau existant la différenciation
de notre réseau par rapport aux autres
clubs nous nous nous nous enregistrons
pas vraiment comme un club mais plutôt
comme un réseau parce que nous donnons
l'opportunité en fait à des
entrepreneurs de se retrouver sur des
ateliers collectifs d'intelligence
collective justement en utilisant des
méthodes comme le design thinking ou
d'autres méthodes de créativité que nous
allons proposer justement aux visiteurs
de faire vivre l'expérience pendant ce
salon soit les objectifs finalement de
créer des synergies des interactions
entre entre ses acteurs ses
entrepreneurs saignements alors pas
seulement entre les entrepreneurs
indépendants parce que effectivement
c'est le propos de contrepoint 78 c'est
vraiment d'aider les entrepreneurs
indépendants ses délires ceux qui ont
choisi ou pas choisi mais enfin qui sont
tout seuls pour travailler et qui
représentent autant d' expertise qui
viennent apporter en fait une expertise
utile tant au développement des
entreprises à la création au
développement ou retournement des
entreprises très important est le
troisième thème va être défi
entreprendre c'est savoir innover
parce que effectivement il faut être
capable de savoir rebondir et de savoir
s'adapter au marché qui évolue sans
cesse s'est posé de nouvelles solutions
donnera l'occasion de l'évoquer mais
qu'avec mes autres invités vous l'avez
dit c'est le credo 1 de quoi
entreprendre 78 de rompre de l'
isolement
et cette première édition comment elle
vous est venu à l'idée ce qu'il avait
une demande justement au sein de ce
réseau entreprendre a tout à fait la
forte demande c'est d'être visible
d'être rendue visible alors pas
seulement
dans le milieu des entrepreneurs et des
clubs d'entrepreneurs ou là c'est assez
facile de se rendre visible à versailles
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de clubs n'est
ce pas mais surtout la grande difficulté
c'est ce pour quoi nous existons c'est
de les rendre visibles auprès des
managers en fait de grands groupes ou de
pme ou de dirigeants même de tpe qui
peuvent tout à fait avoir besoin de
telle ou telle expertise dans parmi nos
entrepreneurs et vous parlez du
territoire de versailles on est aussi
sur un territoire tout proche de saint
quentin en yvelines qui est le deuxième
pôle économique de l'ouest parisien on
est à proximité aussi du du plateau de
saclay donc forcément un territoire
aussi intéressant pour organiser ce
genre d'événement passionnant tout à
fait alors en réalité contrepoint de
soissons 2018 rayonne à une heure autour
de versailles donc vous voyez que nous
abordons tout à fait nous avons
d'ailleurs même des sponsors qui
viennent de l'est des clayes-sous-bois
cité ça tout à l'heure nous avons donc
un certain nombre d'entrepreneurs qui
viennent même de l'essonne
voyez une millions d'actions qui étiez
grand le programme du salon qu'elle est
il que faut-il retenir de ce programme
et bien alors nous avons un salon en
trois actes comme une pièce de théâtre
premier acte s'est effectivement cette
journée d'ateliers conférences avec des
moments forts en fait d'intelligence
collective soit avec des speakers en
fait qui vont parler vraiment de cases
usage l'un de leurs méthodes innovantes
d'entrepreneuriat donc on a
bien sûr le lean start up on va aborder
aussi la marque employeur qui est un
sujet assez récent pour voir comment
concrètement elle l'est devient
accessible pas seulement aux grands
groupes mais aussi aux tpe pme
on va aborder bien sûr le bien recruter
durablement mais la formation
professionnelle car il faut rester
compétitif que l'on soit seul ou que
l'on soit en entreprise
on va aborder différents sujets
l'intelligence artificielle aussi
comment innover dans son business avec
l'intelligence artificielle c'est pas
forcément être chercheur mais c'est
peut-être des petites applications qui
peuvent vraiment améliorer la vie
quotidienne de l'entrepreneur et rendre
beaucoup plus visibles tels ou tels
artisans commerçants un peu plus isolé
dans son territoire
comment on y participe à ce salon et
bien tout simplement en fait l'entrée
gratuite toutefois il faut s'inscrire
donc on a un site en secret ainsi
actuellement avec bravo merci beaucoup
et donc ils s'appellent défi
entreprendre points comme c'est tout
simple et par contre faut bien attacher
les mots défi entreprendre points comme
pour atteindre notre site sur lequel
vous trouvez non seulement les trente
experts qui vont intervenir mais aussi
le déroulé avec le timing de la du
programme ateliers conférences et les
différents moments forts de cette
journée locaux lunch l'eulex launch in
english
et le soir un afterwork bien
naturellement en cocktail de clôture
mais quel est l'objectif clous fixés
pour que cette première justement soit
une réussite
écoutez là il se trouve qu'on a boo
succès en terme de nombre de visiteurs
puisque là on est déjà 160 visiteurs
inscrits toutefois ce n'était pas
vraiment le nombre que l'on visait
simplement c'était aussi arriver à faire
venir des managers de grands groupes
et il se trouve qu'on est assez content
parce qu'effectivement on va avoir
quelques grands groupes qui vont être
présents comme safran lafarge bull
construction schneider
que j'imaginais pas forcément au départ
salon un défi entreprendre ce vendredi
au domaine de madame elisabeth à
versailles de 11h à 18h merci lindo g co
présidente de entreprendre corps
coprésidents présidente de cour
entreprendre 78 je vais y arriver avec
qui organise bien sûr ce salon merci à
vous mais deux autres invités se sont
justement lancer dans le défi de
l'entrepreneuriat polka c est pire de
châteaubourg cofondateurs de la start up
caps vous êtes un cube et à l'école
polytechnique sur le plateau de saclay
aussi par l'école de l'essec
c'est un accompagnement justement
primordiale pour la réussite dans votre
entreprise
justement comme ça vient d'être révoqué
pour nous ça a été crucial de développer
un réseau de rencontrer d'autres gens
qu'ils entreprenaient aussi juste pour
avoir un retour d'expérience de savoir
les avoir à faire et ne pas faire
et puis d'avoir une sorte de mentorat
sur certains sujets qui peuvent être
compliqué quand on aborde les
entrepreneurs et alors vous travaillez
sur un projet de capsule volante qui
pourrait être une solution à l'avenir
pour les déplacements urbains ça
s'appelle caps pourquoi partir sur ce
projet est ce que les le constat
aujourd'hui qu'on peut faire la
saturation des axes routiers notamment
en ile de france et que ça c'est l'une
des raisons qui vous a poussé à
travailler sur sur ce sujet là son
principal je pense c'est plutôt le
constat finalement que c'était devenu
faisable ces dernières années il ya des
belles avancées dans le domaine des
batteries et man on est capable
finalement de construire des appareils
qui sauf un qui ont la capacité de
porter finalement sans avoir une
batterie sinon que ça qu'ils ont la
capacité de porter une ou plusieurs
personnes
donc à partir de ce constat là on a
voulu faire dans ce domaine là la
voiture volante et on s'est rendu compte
que finalement la meilleure application
qu'on aurait pu en avoir
c'était dans les villes parce qu'il ya
quand même pas mal de problèmes
d'embouteillage de pollution et autant
de problèmes qu'on essaye de répondre
avec cet appareil est ce que la voiture
volante c'est un vieux fantasme qui est
né dans les romans de science-fiction
aussi dans dans différents films
aujourd'hui vous le dites on a les
capacités techniques pour réaliser de
tels projets
ok c'est uniquement faire voler une
voiture c'est possible il reste encore
quelques contraintes techniques
notamment
dans le cas de figure où il y aurait
toute une flotte de voitures volantes
qui survolerait un espace aérien
ça serait des problèmes techniques
d'interaction et de gestion pour ne pas
avoir de collision au large et en termes
de coûts est ce que c'est aussi
réalisable aujourd'hui
tout dépend c'est à dire en termes de
coûts sa demande évidemment des grosses
sommes d'investissement les premières
voitures volantes qui se consomme marché
pour des particuliers
on est déjà de l'ordre du demi million
du million d'euros par contre nous faire
notre solution c'est pas forcément de
vendre à des particuliers
c'est de faire la voiture la plus
économique possible finalement leur
semblera pas tant que ça à une voiture
mais plutôt à une capsule porté par un
drone est notre objectif c'est de faire
des finalement des courses de taxi en
pointe ou paint à prix abordable pour le
client c'est à dire une vingtaine
d'euros au grand maximum
donc voici à quoi pourrait ressembler
cette caps comment ça fonctionnerait
concrètement vous l'avez dit soussou
modèle des taxis finalement taxi volant
tout à fait en fait on pourrait
commander l'appareil via notre téléphone
on installerait nous-mêmes plusieurs
stations dans la ville et de par son
téléphone il peut choisir et la station
départ la station d'arrivée puis à
partir du moment où l'appareil commandé
il va partir de sa station de stockage
se poser à la borne d'atterrissage
proche du client et l'emporter là où il
fallait finalement et le coût d'une cour
j'imagine que l'objectif c'est aussi de
le rendre accessible au plus grand
nombre
le coût d'une course avec cette caps une
censure va avoir un jour un impact sur
la congestion des villes sur la
pollution faut imaginer ça a une
certaine ampleur et comme l'a dit mon
collègue on espère fusé des prix aux
alentours de 20 euros maximum pour une
course et ça demanderait quelles
infrastructures à mettre en place quels
types d'infrastructures il faudrait
mettre en place dans les villes
justement tout dépend finalement il ya
pas mal de nos concurrents qui sont déjà
pas mal avancé qui construisent des
voitures volantes pour plusieurs
personnes donc des gros taxi et
finalement ce genre d'appareil aura
besoin d'héliport n'ont pour l'instant
c'est pas accessible à la majorité des
villes tandis que nous on fait un
appareil monoplace et on le design pour
qu'ils soient le plus fin possible pour
qu'il puisse atterrir au sol un peu
partout et c'est pour ça que notre
infrastructure nous la développons aussi
donc on tend à développer notre propre
station d'atterrissage
avec un impératif du imagine aussi c'est
proposer une solution de transport
totalement écologique est aussi
silencieuse parce que c'est des
thématiques qui reviennent souvent
aujourd'hui
dans les demandes de transport en effet
la partie silencieuse un impact qui est
très fort psychologiquement vis-à-vis
des populations surtout quand on parle
d'aéronefs
nous allons développer la nef le plus
petit comme ça vient d'être dit un
monoplace et le bruit vient en fonction
du poids ou du volume de l'appareil en
développant l'appareil le plus petit
possible
nous imaginons quelque chose de très
silencieux en plus de ça à la hauteur à
laquelle l'appareil se déplacera qui
dépendra énormément de régulation nous
l'imaginons hauteur d'une cinquantaine
de mètres permettrait de ne pas avoir de
nuisances sonores
en fait s'il ya des territoires propices
où vous imaginez déjà cette capsule
volantes se se développer alors
forcément le territoire qui nous
intéresse ici c'est de prime abord saint
quentin en yvelines est ce que ce type
d'agglomération l'agglomération urbaine
ça pourrait être un territoire propice
pour voir se développer ce type de
déplacement tout à fait la manière dont
on l'a inventé finalement cette solution
c'était plutôt regarder des villes
européennes puisque les villes
asiatiques et américaines sont
finalement trop large la capacité de
l'appareil reste quand même réduite et
donc du coup s'il est possible de
traverser tout paris ou faire saint
quentin en yvelines paris sur un seul
trajet on se voit mal du coup de travail
y travailler traverser une ville comme
comme dubaï qui est finalement bien plus
large que la région parisienne puisque
des territoires qui sont déjà intéressés
qui voilà qui ont montré de l'intérêt
pour votre projet alors lorsqu'on a
commencé notre projet nous sommes allés
voir plusieurs
responsable de mobilité dans différentes
villes et métropoles françaises pour
savoir si tout simplement nous
développons solution qui était
intéressante
les retours des instances de mobilité et
que c'est un projet très intéressant et
qui vient compléter et ajouter un
dynamisme dans certaines métropoles
reste à voir les réglementations en dvd
pour pouvoir les réglementations
aujourd'hui elle est très strictes en
termes de transport aérien c'est ça de
passagers pour l'instant il n'existe pas
donc le mot pour enfin la réglementation
s'est pas de voiture volante
actuellement donc du coup c'est voué à
évoluer dans les années à venir plus tôt
d'ici d'une dizaine d'années on parle
déjà de taxi volant pour les jeux
olympiques de 2024 à paris donc ça
pourrait évoluer très vite ça c'est
possible que se forme d'ici 2024 que ce
soit enfin qu' une exposition au grand
public mais je doute qu'il y ait une
masse importante de gens qui puissent se
permettre des trajets surtout au dessus
de paris qui est pas mal réglementée
du coup derrière chose quel est le
calendrier alors du coup vous vous fixez
nous avons pour objectif dans l'est dans
l'année qui vient de terminer un premier
prototype de démonstration et avec une
certaine mauvaise foi pour pouvoir
mettre en place un système perrin de r&d
sur plusieurs années car c'est
principalement le sujet de notre
entreprise c'est la r&d dans ce domaine
un domaine qui évolue rapidement c'est
le transport real est ce qu on a eu une
année déjà on pourrait voir en vol cette
capsule or pourquoi pas dans un premier
temps pour du transport de marchandises
on peut imaginer alors dans un premier
temps on l'a pas imaginer fin on s'est
intéressé au transport de marchandises
mais on s'est rendu compte qu'elle
n'était pas particulièrement adaptés par
contre on peut l'imaginer dans un
transport de personnes et plus avec une
optique touristique en dehors des villes
donc moins de réglementation donc par
exemple en plus imaginer ça je n'ai pas
en auvergne si vous avez envie de voir
ma les volcans d'en haut on peut
simplement s'en servir comme un
ascenseur vers le ciel et du coup une
simple attraction touristique qui
donnerait une vision sur la région
suivre avec attention l'évolution de ce
projet merci à vous deux pôles cassé
pierre de châteaubourg je rappelle vous
êtes les cofondateurs de la start up
caps qui projette donc il développe en
ce moment cette capsule volante en
attendant justement la capsule volantes
les piétons et cyclistes peuvent déjà se
rendre de limay à mantes la jolie est la
grande passerelle qui relie les deux
villes en passant par la scène a été
inauguré à tout récemment une structure
en acier en bois maintenant
aldo pour les précisions les villes de
mantes-la-jolie élimé sont reliés la
grande passerelle qui rejoint la place
de l'étape à mantes la jolie à proximité
de la collégiale au théâtre de verdure
situé sur l'île aux dames est désormais
ouverte aux cyclistes et piétons
ce chantier a débuté en février 2018 le
pont existant est extrêmement utilisez
donc l'idée c'était de donner plus de
place
c'est de donner plus de place aux
sécurité donc du coup on a voulu
profiter de cette opportunité de créer
une vraie passerelle un projet attendu
depuis bien longtemps pour cet ancien
maire de mantes-la-jolie qui prévoit
également une autre passerelle en
circulation douce cette idée était née
en 1999 donc vingt ans plus tard l'avoir
réalisé c'est très important
et puis avec l'arrivée des halls sur le
territoire de menthe et plus largement
sur la vallée de seine
il est impératif qu'il y ait des
liaisons améliorée entre les deux rives
la rive droite et la rive gauche
on s'est même entendu avec le président
devedjian vous savez que nos deux
départements aspire à fusionner pour que
le long de la voie ferrée et hall entre
ouïe et dentaire il y est aussi une
passerelle en circulation douce et que
nous fidèles seront tous les deux cette
passerelle un des nouveaux éléments en
faveur de la mobilité douce finances en
majorité par la région ile de france
un coup de 9,6 millions d'euros qu'il
faut construire ces passerelles parce
qu'elles permettent là encore des
nouvelles liaisons peut-être pas en
voiture mais des liaisons 12 et liaison
vélo qui permettent de d'éviter les
embouteillages qui sont vraiment la
plaie des yvelinois et notamment le soir
et le matin à partir de février 2020
l'aide à l'achat de vélos électriques
sera proposé d'une valeur de 500 euros
pour chaque francilien dans l'actualité
locale également de la politique est
long cours la campagne pour les
municipales est lancée après le maire
sortant jean michel fourgous à la fin de
l'année 2018 est d'autres candidats ont
annoncé leur souhait de se présenter une
liste de gauche est en cours de création
notamment un marylène yapi shiloh et
mélanie poké c'est leur première réunion
publique le collectif réinventons et
l'encours s'est rassemblée ce samedi un
collectif composé d'une quinzaine de
personnes qui entend instaurer le débat
avec la population
c'est surtout la méthode
l'homme qui me semble tout à fait
intéressante à savoir qu' on veut faire
émerger de l'ensemble des citoyens et
bien un projet de ville voilà une
orientation générale des méthodes et des
contenus qu'ils soient à l'image des
habitants
si la tête de liste n'a pas encore été
désignés les organisateurs de cette
réunion revendique déjà un programme des
fonds dans des valeurs de gauche
moi effectivement je suis membre de
génération mais quelques-uns gelé dire
l'introduction il ya des militants qui
sont engagés au pca génération certains
au ps il ya aussi des gens qui sont
plutôt engagés dans les associations de
la ville et puis des gens qui sont pas
forcément on pas forcément d'engagement
en tout cas jusqu'ici
donc c'est vraiment une liste assez
varié donc pour l'instant on n'a pas y'a
pas de label pausé maire sortant les
républicains et président de saint
quentin en yvelines jean michel fourgous
à lui déjà officialisé sa candidature
pour mars 2020 le reste de l'actualité
en bref il est jugé non conforme
l'arrêté anti pesticides pris par la
mère du perray en yvelines a été
suspendu par le tribunal administratif
de versailles en mai dernier et paulette
deschamps avait décidé d'interdire dans
sa commune l épandage de glyphosate à
moins de 150 mètres des habitations
le juge a considéré que cette mesure ne
rentrait pas dans les prérogatives d'un
édile un arrêté similaire a été appris
également également par la mer des devis
elle a été convoquée devant le tribunal
administratif le 4 octobre prochain
eux dénoncent les actes des attaques
dont ils sont victimes et notamment à
cause des pesticides les agriculteurs
sont mobilisés toute la semaine à
l'appel de la fdsea et des jeunes
agriculteurs
hier soir ils se sont réunis à part et
doivent ils jouent sur ces images mais
aussi au péage de buchelay de
saint-arnoult dans leur ville et au
niveau de joueur pontchartrain et de
gambe et à proximité de la n 12
une action qui va se poursuivre toute
cette semaine jusqu'à vendredi est
d'ailleurs agriculteurs et élus seront
nos invités demain mercredi pour le
premier numéro de la saison du 7-8 débat
émission consacrée à l'utilisation des
pesticides 265 mille participants et
plus de 4000 événements en france pour
le world cleanup des l'un d'entre eux
était samedi
aux clayes-sous-bois porté par la maison
de la jeunesse et de la culture rejointe
par d'autres organisations marylène
iapichino les a suivis tout au long de
la matinée
ce matin la colombe a enfilé gants et
gilet jaune pour nettoyer sa commune
voilà une bouteille pour les mégots on a
un sac pour m le plastique
on a une bouteille en verre aussi j'en
effectuera un second trait à l'issue de
la balade
comme elle ils sont 70 à s'être relevé
de bon matin pour participer c'est la
deuxième année que se déroule ce grand
nettoyage vous faire en groupes ont été
constitués et chaque groupe fait en fait
un itinéraire très précis qui a été
tracé stabilo durant deux heures ils
sillonnent la ville et traquent le monde
riche et ce prêt des banques qu'on
trouve la plupart des mégots et à chaque
fois on remplit quasiment une bouteille
entière
donc ils focalisent l'attention sur les
parcs
j'ai pas toutes les citer mais voilà il
ya quand même plusieurs associations que
les siennes qui se sont joints à nous il
faut savoir que c'est un événement qui
est international qui a une déclinaison
française et qui voit là que donc du
coup on s'inscrit aussi dans quelque
chose d'assez globale au bout du périple
les équipes se retrouvent et mettre en
commun leurs récoltes fier du travail
accompli
je fais très attention parce que je suis
je suis déjà éco-délégués policiers au
lycée sonia-delaunay qui a dit le pr et
et non c'est quelque chose qui me tient
qui me tient à coeur
on fait plein de projets et puis c'est
vrai que voilà l'écologie c'est vraiment
un problème majeur dans notre dans nos
sociétés au total en deux heures 173 kg
de déchets ont été ramassées aux
clayes-sous-bois dont 5,8 de mégots de
cigarettes
le potager urbain qui fait face à la
mairie de bois d'arcy évolué créé en
2015 par le mouvement des incroyables
comestibles il accueille désormais une
spirale aromatiques explications avec
patrick jacques de dixmude et maxime
abolin c'est la troisième spirale
aromatiques de france
après metz et chambéry cette innovation
s'installe à bois d'arcy
la spirale a été inaugurée par les
incroyables comestibles un mouvement
citoyen et solidaire d'agriculture
urbaine participative d1 croate
comestibles reconnecte les gens entre
eux et à la terre nourricière
le principe c'est que nos actions sont
totalement ouvertes elles sont ouvertes
à tous chacun peut venir à aider à faire
les plantations l'entretien mais
également venir partager des récoltes et
ce ne sont pas forcément les mêmes
personnes qui ont planté entretenu et
ceux qui vont effectivement partagé des
récoltes reprendre contrôle de ce qu'on
mange de la façon dont ses produits
et qui dit prendre le contrôle de ce
qu'on mange signifie aussi prendre le
contrôle de notre santé et bien sûr
alors que si son jardin solidaire existe
en france à bois d'arcy on retrouve un
lieu unique en coopération avec
sanoflore c'est une spirale
d'aromatiques entre eux principalement
des plantes aromatiques et médicinales
on aura l'année prochaine sont nos trois
spirale à peu près une quarantaine de
plantation différentes un nombre
d'essences de plantes différentes
le conseil municipal des jeunes un
groupe scout et visons fond d'une école
élémentaire participent au projet mais
l'initiative est ouverte à tous quand on
voit l'état de la planète aujourd'hui je
pense que ce genre d'initiative faut que
ça se multiplie à l'infini
je pense que c'est important de se
rappeler qu'un légume ça pousse dans la
terre et pour moi c'est vraiment
important essayer d'encourager même les
jeunes pour comprendre qu'il faut que je
prenne les choses en main pour l'avenir
et que ça dépend de nous et on peut
faire de très belles choses ensemble
projet l'objectif pour les incroyables
comestibles de bois d'arcy continuer son
développement à l'échelle locale et
pourquoi pas nourrir toute la ville
grâce à ces jardins participatifs
avant de refermer ce journal une pensée
pour antoine farruggia l'entraîneur
emblématique fondateur du boxing club
d'elancourt 50 en yvelines nous quittait
il ya cinq ans des suites d'un cancer
une carrière sur et surtout en dehors
des rings sous sa houlette sont devenus
champions de france et d'europe nasser
la crypte faouzi à thème ou plus
récemment a dit la môme a dit antoine
farruggia avait à 70 ans c'est la fin de
ce journal dans un instant vous
retrouvez l'émission 7,8 culture
présentée par aurélie ronces belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]